girls i meet are divided into those who
have intellectual interests
like sensitive men um but are very woke
and the less woke who are not very
intellectual who seem to be consumerists
and prefer traditional gender roles
as a young man how can i date today well
that's a really
bleak binary picture that you have
painted
uh and i don't envy anyone being young
and entering the dating market right now
i guess i'm i'm a little devastated
about that description
i know there are people who young women
who are both intellectual and not woke
but i don't know where they hang out
particularly used to hang out in our
classrooms but those don't exist anymore
yeah but i think the thing is we even
know that many of the
young women who were in our classrooms
uh
you know continue into the world some of
them remain
single and some of them are not but i
think the thing is they suggest
a fact which is many many people are
finding something
very troubling in the mating and dating
market and
my recommendation would be you figure
out
the mechanism you're using to figure out
who to date is directing you to people
who fall into one of two categories that
you don't
resonate with um the key to figure out
how to define
and uh maybe create
that that third fourth fifth whatever it
is category uh that will have people in
it who you're
more interested in yes where would those
people tend i mean you know if they are
decrying the lack of
men who uh fit with their model we
certainly
i mean this is now a couple of years old
but we certainly would hear from
students of both sexes straight students
from
of both sexes that they were having a
very hard time finding people
uh with whom they're interested in
having a relationship yeah and
i you know for the most part this wasn't
about their standards being ridiculous
right no i think in large measure it has
to do
with um almost everybody below a certain
age having been
sold a false bill of goods about
what is valuable and that in some sense
you're looking for the people who know
that the description of what they're
supposed to be pursuing
is hollow and you know largely driven by
people who want to sell you something
rather than people who are actually
looking out for your interest so
my recommendation would be figure out
how to escape that you're looking for
oddballs
that could be a very rewarding
relationship or
search for a relationship and when you
find the right person
where do you find the oddballs like what
it depends on what kind of oddballs you
want
you know one of my first guesses would
be um
[Music]
look for people who are doing something
physical you know backpacking clubs or
bicycling or
you know sports teams you know summer
leagues pick up
pickup games of something that are co-ed
ultimate frisbee being particularly
um responsive to co-ed sport
um just because as i've said many many
times and you have said as well
uh engaging with the world physically
makes it
really so much harder to accept a lot of
the the woke garbage that
requires that you sort of have no
feedback from the world and you know
physical engagement with the world gives
you that feedback and so you get to you
hone your insight
and i i think i mean this is now
hypothesis but given that i've seen so
few people who are you know
rock climbers or carpenters or you know
otherwise engaging the world in a real
way
who are also really buying into the bulk
stuff i think that it basically hones
your brain such that it's harder for you
to accept that totally
socially created conclusions that
intersectional [ __ ] provides
what i'm having the thought of
a um a shirt for the
postmodern rock climbing club in which
the shirt depicts a cliff rising above
the cliff
is the sound of somebody falling ah
[Music]
because that's what would happen in
post-modern rock climbing yeah um i mean
it could just
even be post-modern rock climbing club
and could have the coyote suspended
above cliff not recognizing uh
gravity yet yes oh that too there you go
that's that's the point that uh the idea
that it doesn't
the rules of physics don't apply to you
until you recognize that they're there
is super amusing when it's a cartoon
coyote but not so amusing when you're
actually contending with these people uh
for
over issues of you know whether or not
to defund the police
i thought that cartoon was about market
failure as depicted through the acme
corporation
i think they were doing pretty well for
themselves weren't they i guess they
were yeah
yeah all right um well i would actually
suggest though this is just a proof of
concept but
um you say that you are encountering
uh girls i would suggest you start
searching for women and you are finding
women
who have intellectual interests they
like sensitive men
that's a little suspect
and they're very woke well here's the
thing where would you find
intellectual women who have no patience
for woke
i would say the rationalist community
would be one place you would find such
people now those people are certainly
quirky but they tend to be quirky in a
kind of delightful way so
if that's the dynamic you're trying to
break
seek out a community where that
formulation doesn't make sense
okay i mean right i it seems to me that
maybe it's not all that numerous
well and my guess would also be that the
sex ratio is rather skewed in the
direction that this person writing in
would not prefer
but that's those are those are the
stereotypes i hold in my head that's
true but it's also
like it's a community nested within some
other communities
right and so anyway all i'm saying it's
really it was just a proof of concept
which is there's a place
in which that formulation wouldn't add
up yep so
it's also there will be others and and
you know i'm not suggesting you
take up with the rationalist community
cynically it's also an interesting
community
i think there are some ways in which
there are some things that i don't think
they get as well as they might but you
know we all don't get something as well
as we might and
it would be an interesting place to to
spend time
[Music]
you